the brand new studio display behind me
is set up ready to go but don't worry we
filmed every bit of the unboxing what's
going on guys welcome back to the
channel if you're new here firstly thank
you so much for joining me my name is
david tomic i'm a registered architect
here in western australia and if you
smash that subscribe button right now
along with the notification bell in a
couple weeks you'll get the ultimate
notification
when the brand new mac studio m1 ultra
arrives to perfectly pair with this
device i'm also having some incredibly
annoying problems with it if you want to
check that video out i'm going to put
the little banner up here but without
further ado let's jump into this
unboxing
[Music]
group
[Music]
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and don't forget about the
like button if there's anything you want
to know more of please leave a comment
down below and i'll make sure to reply
to as many people as humanly possible
but until next time that's all from me